a very warm welcome
to all viewers and in this video we will
be looking at
uipath re framework that is robotic
enterprise framework
re framework is an inbuilt template in
ui path studio
stay tuned till the end of the video we
will be discussing robotic enterprise
framework in detail
and at last there is a hands-on demo if
you want to know more about uipath
then you can check out our ui part
tutorial
let's look at today's agenda since the
topic is re framework it's essential to
understand what is framework and
its purpose then we will look at what is
the business process
and different types of it post that we
will understand
what re framework is and look at the
features of re framework
then we will discuss the architecture in
detail
as to how many different states and
transitions are present
and how it works finally we will look at
hands-on demo
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos
then subscribe to our youtube channel
and make sure you press the bell icon
to never miss an update
what is framework and its purpose
the framework is intended to serve as a
blueprint for users to create process
that provide at a bare minimum a way to
store
interpret and easily change project
configuration data
as well as robot exception handling
scheme and event logging
for all exceptions and related
transaction information
the system locks messages at each
relevant stage
in the process of resolving a business
transaction
and sends those logs to the orchestrator
server
this in turn can be linked to the elk
stack which is elasticsearch
log stack and kibana platform which
allows for data storage
and a variety of different ways to
represent the data
the purpose of our framework is to
resolve a set of business transaction
a transaction is a small amount of data
and the steps needed to process it
to complete a segment of business
process a process
that reads a single email from a mailbox
and extracts data from it is a good
example
what is a business process
the sum of actions by which the data
required for a series of transactions
is collected processed and input into
or out of an it resource is referred to
as a business process
we can classify business process into
three groups
based on the steps involved and how they
are repeated
linear the steps of linear process are
only done once
and if different data needs to be
processed the automation must be run
again
iterative the steps of iterative process
are repeated several times but different
data items
are used every time transactional
transactional systems like iterative
process
have steps that replicate several times
over various data objects
what is re framework
the robotic enterprise framework is a
state machine based
project template the template includes
several ready-to-use state containers
for launching applications
retrieving data processing it and
closing the transaction
these states are linked together by a
series of transactions
that cover almost every requirement in a
typical automation scenario
several workflows have been triggered
each of which deals with a different
aspect of project
it's designed to incorporate all of the
industry's best practices
for logging exception management
application initialization
and other areas showing it to handle
even the most complex business
situations
let's look at the features of re
framework the three features are
settings
logging and business application
exception
settings during the initialization phase
of several process
some configuration settings and
configuration values are frequently read
like urls to the web application
orchestrator queue names
and default logging messages the re
framework maintains the track of this
information
by reading it from a configuration file
and storing it in a different
dictionary object shared by all states
instead of updating workflows directly
this provides a simple way to manage
projects by adjusting values in the
configuration file
logging the built-in locking mechanism
is another helpful feature of
re framework the majority of system
workflows
use log message activities to output
information
about what is happening at each stage of
execution
this can be used to not only identify
problems and aid in the debugging
process
but also to generate visualization and
reports
about the process execution like how
many invoices are handled every day
how many failures occur and what are the
critical causes of this failure
business and application execution
there may be conditions that occur
during the execution of most process
that are not part of the usual execution
flow and must be resolved to achieve
more efficient automation
if the issue can be resolved by
restarting application
the framework will do so automatically
and attempt to process the transaction
again
such exceptions are known as application
exception
if the issue is with the data or an
underlying business
requirement the system skips the
transaction and moves to the next
such exception are known as business
exception
let's look at the re framework
architecture
the rb framework is implemented as a
state machine
which is a form of workflow with two
advantageous characteristics
states and transitions actions to be
taken
in response to the stated input are
described by states transitions
that switch the execution from one state
to another based on the results of the
state
there are four key states in re
framework that is
initial state get transaction data
process transaction and end process
initial state initialization this is the
point at which the procedure begins
it's an event where the process
initializes the settings
and runs application tests to ensure
that all of the prerequisites for the
process start are met
so initialization transitions so there
are two transition
system exception and successful when
system exception
when a system error is not nothing it
gets transition to the end process
if we have an application exception
during the initialization phase
we don't have enough details to start
the process as a result
we are going to the end process state to
wrap it up
successful when a system error is
nothing it gets transition to get
transaction data
if during the initialization we have no
error then we go to the
get transaction data the next state is
the get transaction state
this state retrieves the next
transaction object this can be a queue
item or a collection
item transaction items are queue items
by default
but this can be modified to meet your
needs this is also the state
where the developer can set the
condition to exit the state
when there are no items to process get
transaction data transitions there are
two transitions
no data and new transaction
no data if the transaction item is
nothing
then we are at the end of our data
collection so we go to the end process
new transaction data if the transaction
item contains data then we process it
next state is the process transaction
state
the process transaction state for the
transaction item obtained in the
previous step
it performs actions and applies logic in
various application
if a transaction item has been processed
the process moves on to the next
transaction item that is available
so there are three process transaction
transitions
success business exception and system
exception
in success if the condition is business
rule exception is nothing
and system error is nothing then the
transition to get transaction data
if there is a business role exception it
is logged and we move on to the next
transition
business exception if the business rule
exception is not nothing
then it gets transition to get
transaction data
if we have a business rule exception we
log it and move to the next transaction
by going to the get transaction data
state system
exception if we have an application
exception we close all programs
kill them if they fail to complete take
a screenshot at the moment
the exception happened and go to init
where we re-initialize our working
environment and begin a new
form of transaction that has failed and
finally we have the end process date
the procedure is completed and the
application opened during the automation
are closed in the end process state
since this is the last state the final
state there are no transition available
in the end process state we'll explore
each one of these states in detail in
the demo let's see the demo now
in this demo we will see how to dispatch
data from the excel file
then we will create queue items and
process these items
and then we will understand the working
of each state in the robotic enterprise
framework in detail
so let's get started first we'll go to
the orchestrator and create a queue
enter cloud platform dot
ui
sign up then go to the orchestrator
the tenant which you have created
select the folder context go to the
folder context
and you can see cues here go to the
queues
and you can see an option to add here
click on
add and enter a queue name
i'll enter it as ref enter any
description if you want
give unique reference yes and
act and you can see
a queue has been added so you can add an
asset as well
to add an asset you can go to add
click here add and enter the asset name
[Music]
and select the type whatever is required
say boolean
and by default be it as false and create
so this is how you create an asset so
let's go to the ui path studio so what
we are
basically doing is we are building two
process
one to feed a queue in the orchestrator
that is a dispatcher process
and one to process transaction from the
queue that is using the robotic
enterprise framework
so in dispatcher process what we do is
we get entries from an excel file and
add them as a queue items in the
orchestrator
we have already created a queue we
started project
as sequence and added a try cat we
started with the sequence
added a try catch activity in the try
block
we used a retrench activity to read
first 10 lines
from a1 to c11 from an excel file and
store them in a newly created data
table variable we used for each row
to loop through the rows of the data
table variable and add each of them in a
queue using the add queue item activity
then we used a log message we use log
message activity
to lock the fact that the dispatching
process was successful
that is how we created the dispatcher
process
now we create a performer
using robotic enterprise framework what
it does is we'll get titles from the
queue and processes
so
[Music]
in the dispatcher process let's go to
the initialization state first
so we'll understand initialization state
in detail
so the entire index block is kept inside
the try catch
if you go to the documents here
if you go to the data folder you can see
a config file here
so config file this is the file we use
in the init state
it has three sheets settings constants
and
assets you can give any
values whatever you want for maximum
retry number
the value should be zero when you are
working with your orchestrator cues the
value should be
zero so this config file is stored in
the data folder
and it has three sheets settings
constants and assets
this is the queue name process abcq or
let's get back to the
framework
so we are initializing system error if
the error is nothing
it will go to the next state if first
run read local configuration file
you can see by default there are many
variables created
you should know them and utilize them
whenever required
the config variable the value type is
dictionary type
config is nothing if you go here
you can see here config is nothing
initially there is no value so initially
config is nothing
then it will input init all settings
workflow
let's open this first run
so it will invoke init all settings
workflow
to see this workflow click on open
workflow
it has three arguments
it has three arguments in config file in
config sheets and out config
this is of type string type string and
out config is of type distance
and direction this is a both our input
and this is
out let's open the workflow and
understand
so basically what this workflow does is
this workflow outputs setting dictionary
with the key value
pairs to be used in the project settings
are referred from the local config
file and then fetch from the
orchestrator assets
assets will overwrite the config file
settings
putting in it all settings workflow
invoked to initialize all settings and
data for application and process
use in this part the setting constant
and assets in the config
file from the data folder are read in
the initialize all settings
so let's go back the orchestrator queue
name
from the from the configuration file in
the argument case
is specified and it provides a backward
compatibility
next we have invoked process
if we go to the arguments here we can
see the
orchestrator queue name you can assign a
queue name here if you have created a
queue
so info kill process
next we have invoke kill process it is
logging activity called killing process
depending on the project you can add
active it is a logging activity
called killing process depending on the
project you can add activities
and add log fields in ad lock fields if
you want to add any details in the log
file
then you can do it using all log fields
init all applications
workflow in this workflow invoked to
open apps and check the status
credentials and
so on and that there are two transitions
in this when it is
successful it gets transition to get
transaction data
when there is a system exception it goes
to the end process
so so in short what initialization state
does is
at the end of this workflow that is the
initialization state it reads the config
file
and stores the key and value inside the
dictionary that is the out config
out configurationary variable has all
config excel file data
let's see the get transaction data
when you are in the orchestrator and you
want to immediately stop a job from for
some reason when the job is stopped
this activity gets activated there is a
variable created
should stop if it's a boolean variable
by default it's false when it gets
activated the value becomes
yes then it will go to the log stop
message as
stop process requested
and it will end the process when the
transaction
item is nothing else it will go to the
try get transaction data
here that it has seven arguments
and let's see the workflow invoke get
transaction data workflow
click on open workflow
it gets the data from the spreadsheets
databases email
web api or ui path server queues if no
new data items
then set out the transaction item to
nothing
if a new transaction item is retrieved
then it gets the additional information
about it it gives the condition
where our transaction item is not
nothing then it will add the transaction
information to the log fields
it is about the get transaction data
workflow
the process transaction state the
process is a sequence with a try catch
activity
set to catch both system exceptions and
business exceptions
inside the try block the process
transaction workflow
invoked that has simple process like to
attach the ui demo application
and three type into activities to fill
in and
click accept button
and if you see look at the transitions
it has three transition
system exception whose destination is
the initialization state
business exception goes back to the get
transaction data
and success it goes to the get
transaction
data finally the end process state
where the applications is closed
that's it about the demo i hope you
liked it if you have
any questions you can ask in the comment
section
so with that we have reached the end of
this video like and share if you found
it interesting
thank you for being here keep learning
stay tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here